Reuben Margolin - Reuben like the
sandwich the nebula is a sculpture that
is going to be installed at the Hilton
Anatole in Dallas Texas
and they're undergoing a major
renovation and the architect for the
project thought a suspended kinetic
artwork would look cool and they had a
competition and they invited me to be
part of that and the first time I showed
up I walked into the atrium and my heart
literally just jumped in my chest
because the space is fantastic and I
kept going back to that original feeling
where I was like wow this is just such a
wonderful space and how do I do justice
to it how do I make something that is
both dramatic and meditative
something that fits well how do I pull
out the elements that are already in the
atrium and so I spent a couple of months
really thinking about the design and
came up with the nebula
I wanted to bring something that was
reminiscent of sort of natural beauty
and something that had the big sort of
sweeping forms of like we seen those
photos of like the starlings or have you
seen like don't we know like the waves
just sort of rippling either in water or
the way a big tree moves and somehow
these large natural rhythms to somehow
get that into the atrium in a way that
was soothing and also dynamic
I kept thinking about this piece I just
completed there's a sense of volume to
it and you can see through it and if
thinking of yours it was right in the
middle of the atrium you could walk all
the way around he's you know the
different sort of the different
balconies that different levels it might
just be really stunning and so I sort of
took this and I had to elongate it to
make it fit into the into this the
atrium and then I also because it got
bigger I had to add a lot more cables to
it so that it would maintain its
fluidity
now in between the ring and the grid
there's this very complicated weave and
this weave distributes a sine wave down
toward a certain pattern and it's that
weave that gives it the movement and
it's that we've also that is really
difficult to install because every cable
has to go over another one and below
this one and on top of that one it's
this 3-dimensional weave and so I've
been spending a lot of time trying to
figure out the easiest way to to
actually physically make that weave
while we're at the hotel was what we're
making more or less except that instead
of being this big it's this part is
going to be as big as my whole building
and a space like the atrium you know you
can look around at giant pieces of art
here in the hotel just kind of swallows
them so the scale of anything has to be
very large here in order to have any
kind of impact the complexity I feel a
little bit more that I have a handle on
I can get in there and figure things out
and work out cable lengths and patterns
but the scale of it I really needed a
lot of help with and I got lucky and met
gizmo Moussa in mark Sabatino in San
Francisco they have this awesome
fabrication shop and they knew this
amazing engineer named Michael GLaDOS
who just Dovan there and took all of
these numbers and sort of figured out
how big the truss had to be and how big
the ring how to be and design this
amazing cable net that could support the
weight of the nebula and so I've been
working really closely with them for the
last you know last bunch of months and
it's coming together
and I struggled for a long time over
what this what this material is going to
be and then one day I was leaving my
house and this bicycle went by and the
Sun hit the bicycle reflector and I saw
this flash I thought oh that's it
so this is one of the crystals for the
nebula the nebula has 4,500 of the
shapes and so that's about 15,000
different bicycle reflectors and each
one has this sort of custom aluminum
cone that's going to be anodized gold
and so the whole thing when it's when
it's moving and the Sun is coming down
in the daytime it should really Sparkle
in the night and bottom later but with a
light from the ground and it should just
really twinkle so I'm really excited to
see all them kind of floating and
swimming in the atrium
you
you hold up a bicycle reflector and you
look at it you say this is going to be a
fantastic 700,000 cubic foot sculpture
one day and you there's a very very
great distance between those two parts
but when you get into and start looking
at the details and sort of looking at
how it's going to work and the layers
that are going to get stacked up and how
these little pieces are going to become
the thousands of those pieces are going
to add up to something that's far
greater than they could have been on
their own it's didn't be learning in
another bicycle reflectors they're not
going to know that they're anodized
aluminum combs we're not going to know
that it's 30 second inch cables not
going to any of this is going to just
see this thing moving in space and be
like that's a beautiful movement that's
a beautiful statement if you look at it
in plan view you would see this sort of
geometric pattern that is made up of
these hexagonal diamonds and each of
these points has a cable going up to the
mechanism that makes it move and I
wanted to make a wave pattern that
rolled through it so it was continually
in motion and ended up with this sort of
modified in the end shape and so these
represent the waves that will be sort of
flowing through it and then I had to go
back and figure out where each of these
points went to on a ring in order to
give the kind of movement that I wanted
I totally love math I mean eventually in
high school I the best math teachers and
all of the math that is in a nebula
pretty much came out of Berkeley high
and so there's a lot of trick and the
trick for instance was used in
calculating all of the various different
cable lengths and the pulley angles and
and a mouth is so amazing in that you
can calculate that this piece of metal
has to be this long and you do that
abstractly and then you go and you put
it in and it fits
that's incredible how does it work and
so this is sort of like a giant math
problem all these little sections are
worked out in the abstract and they
should all fit together to be one final
piece
one of the really exciting things about
that the Dallas piece is that we'll have
no idea what it's actually going to look
like until its installed in other words
it's impossible we have all the parts we
can test this cable and we can test the
ring or we can test various components
but we're not going to put it together
until we're actually in the atrium for
the first time lifting it up and adding
all the crystals and so it just is like
that unknown is just like such a
wonderful like sense of excitement
really a driving force to completing it
this is 11,000 pounds of material hand
over people's heads if anything fails
it's going to be a huge disaster mersive
would yeah knock on wood